like one through three three all right
i'm gonna see all right here we go
want to see an awkward moment between
stone cold steve austin and paul heyman
just don't call steve austin what is it
payday
very close mike read the title of the
video
hang out with us i'm a jew and my people
we're not hunters we're furriers you
know
i mean right you see the whole crew's
laughing now about that especially the
guy over there who's jewish
because he knows because you know it's
like i can't kill the thing
but i can make you a nice lapel out of
it why don't you get in the diamonds as
well
how you all in as you would said
diamonds
first a movie business what's the deal
here it's my dom
oh no oh oh stone
cold oh i love you oh
you're going to be apologizing oh you're
going to be a party
until the uh wait watch watch paul
heyman
you want what watch this next scene all
in as
you would said diamonds furs a movie
business what's the deal here
it's monopoly what
what oh this is
bro this is i am
oh oh i have douche shield look i have
literally no shields i am
so uncomfortable and for you guys
you guys you know may not know this
about me but i really honestly like and
i know royce is very similar i legit
get off on being as close to these
situations as possible
but without being either the perpetrator
or the victim
but i love say i would have given a
million dollars to be able to just be in
that production both watching this
because i would have just been like
oh business what's the deal here
monopoly
what what what
what people my people
we own everything
you're you're and look by the way stone
cold is not
they're gonna make it now of course
they're gonna make him into something of
course not
i guarantee you but he's not
stone cold is a ball breaker you know
and he's just
a guy that you can tell may not be the
funniest guy on the fly all the time but
he likes to just break balls
and he just stepped and [ __ ] and then it
just got like
what what happened what would you say no
what did you just say
i didn't sing what are you talking about
yeah i'm sorry i have to
see that let's watch it through the
whole thing let's watch the whole thing
all right here we go
i'm a jew and my people we're not
hunters
we're furriers you know i mean right you
see the whole crew's laughing now about
that
especially the guy over there who's
jewish because he knows because you know
it's like
i can't kill the thing but i can make
you a nice lapel out of it why don't you
get in the diamonds as well
how you all in as you would said
diamonds
furs a movie business what's the deal
here it's monopoly
what what what
what people my people
we
we're the jews you know we screwed up in
the middle east you know i mean we did i
mean yeah
and i can i can speak about that now
look i'm i'm going to give hayman credit
because i'm being based and honestly
legit friends in real life with good
friends but you can still tell he's a
bit
bothered he is but he could have buried
him if he wanted to
but he kind of started playing along
with him kind of like
you know but you could t he was taken
aback you could tell he's bothered by it
yeah but
like royce is saying he's also seeing
his friend like he's
trying to step in [ __ ] i'm gonna get you
out of this the last thing you need is
vince down your ass
but wow man just because i mean
it was supposed to be the chosen people
and here we you know and then here we
pick the only piece of land in the
middle east
that has no oil on it everything we have
is sand
and the mediterranean sea and military
aid from the biggest biggest [ __ ] the
most powerful country on the planet
yeah it's okay you've you've managed to
do all you've done
pretty well generations people been
trying to push us out into
you know every jewish holiday is the
same thing they tried to kill us and
were still alive
so i mean you know so that's that's the
clip
um that was that was that's really rough
so uncomfortable but it's so awesome by
the way based stone cold right there
based on cold steve austin
what is it with you guys by the way if
you [ __ ] people try to take down
stone cold steve austin i will circle
the wagons for that man
he is my childhood i will circle the
wagons for him